grande nouvelle dans le monde la
paléoanthropologie la découverte d'une
nouvelle espèce apparentée au genre
humain au monde n'allait dit un de nos
lointains cousins mis primates mi homme
moderne qui aurait vécu il ya très
longtemps speeches reggina c'est en
afrique du sud une équipe de chercheurs
financée par la national geographic ce
ça a été a débusqué au monal dit les
restes de notre cousin lointain se
trouvaient au fond d'une série de
grottes profondes dont le dernier
passage était si étroits que seules des
femmes spéléologues très minces pouvait
le franchir mais au bout de ce couloir
quels trésors 1500 ossements fossilisés
au total plus d'une quinzaine de
squelettes en excellente condition
du jamais vu en paléoanthropologie
michel drapeau de l'université de
montréal a été consulté par les
chercheurs
donc non seulement on n' de la
morphologie l'espèce mon idée ou si la
variation de l'espèce entre les hommes
et les femmes est aussi liée à l'âge
parce qu'on a des tout petits pour des
très grands on peut affirmer comme on a
les dix était plus petite nous et qu'il
avait un cerveau à peine plus gros
qu'une orange
par contre il avait des mains semblable
au nôtre et surtout des pieds
presqu'identique qui lui permettait de
parcourir de longues distances
il s'agit donc de l'hybride un autre des
chaînons manquants de notre arbre
généalogique
on découvre en fait qu'un énormément
d'espèces éteintes qui étaient des
culs-de-sac évolutif d'un gros buissons
avec un nom très très grand fayt
d'espèces qui ont pas laissé descendants
nous on est branché un peu chanceuse qui
a survécu à tout ce qui s'est passé
selon les chercheurs la présence de tous
ces squelettes au même endroit laisse
croire comme on est les dix utilisaient
cette grotte comme un cimetière
une hypothèse très intéressante mais qui
ne repose pas encore sur des preuves
vraiment solide ici norma grondin radio
canada